Is there a way
for the digital
experiences thatwe create
to truly enrich our physical lives?
That digital culture would be described today
as an augmented reality metaverse.
We could use this tool to simply
cover the world.
Orwe could use it
to further connect us to this world.
You could leave a digital artwork
on the street corner for your lover to find.
You could reinvent your backyard with
ananimated treasure hunt
for your kids and their friends.
The digital worlds we build
can be awonderful playground
for exploring identity,
for learning new skills,
for practicingcreativity
and bringing our communities together.